- Dear girl,
often times,
we women start to rise and
then certain people devise
a plan to disenfranchise.
Whether it's our bodies or rights,
entice us with movements,
unite us through persecution,
make it seem like it's alright.
Dear girl, open your eyes.
We have come so far, it's easy to resign.
We've got equality, but public
policy shows the contrary.
Honestly, no surprise since
we perpetuate rape culture,
separate locker room talk
in that one audio tape,
that's great.
I get 78 cents to a man's dollar
while black and latino
women get even smaller.
What should every girl know?
You are not some puppet in a puppet show.
Expose the double standards,
the hypocrisy, the hate.
It is never too late.
This is the moment of
girls taking the reins.
It is time's up, it is me too,
it is everyone from me to you
who has spoken or stayed
silent, but strong.
It is Emma Gonzales and Lena Waithe
from dodging bullets and dodging hate.
Christine Blasey Ford and
every survivor that speaks
only to be met with intimidation,
investigation, and disbelief.
Dear girl, you will be believed.
If not by Senate floors and investigators,
we will hear you.
Dear girl, we will see you.
Dear girl, we will stand by you.
For the survivor 3,000 miles
away or the one next door,
you are heard.
Justice will not always prevail,
but we will continue to
fight tooth and nail.
You are heard.
So that our sisters and
daughters will never be asked,
rather, harassed
whether they wanted it,
regretted it, or just forgot.
Believe me, no one forgot.
Dear everyone, this moment is a movement.
For every girl to reclaim
her place, win every race.
For everyone out there, listen in.
The system is in demolition.
Gran ahold of your voice,
it is time to make a choice
to believe survivors,
to pay us all the same,
to give women of color equal
access and opportunity,
to protect the safety of
trans girls every day.
Make the choice to change the climate.
Make the choice to not stay silent.
This is not just the day of the girl,
this is the future of girls.
(somber music)